die gefahr eines atomkrieges ist real
innerhalb von sekunden kann als leicht
falsch interpretiert das eigentlich
harmloses ereignis zum auslöser einer
atomkatastrophe werden manche länder
wie nordkorea versuchen sie sogar zu
provozieren doch nicht nur die direkte
zerstörung durch die atomwaffen selbst
und ihre radioaktive strahlung die
unzählige menschenleben kosten würden
wäre die eigentliche katastrophe eines
atomkrieges die wirkliche katastrophe
eines atomaren schlagabtausches wäre
eine andere was genau wohl mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit das gesamte leben wie
wir es bisher kennen auf dieser welt
aufrücken würde erfahrt ihr jetzt bei
klick zum fixen herzlich willkommen
august 145 zwei atombomben lösen
jeweils eine riesige druckwelle aus die
innerhalb von sekunden die japanischen
städte hiroshima und nagasaki und ihre
umgebung dem erdboden gleichmachen
zehntausende menschen verbrennen so
unvorstellbar tragisch die konsequenten
der beiden atombomben von 125 waren umso
tragischer ist dass die heutigen
atomwaffen sogar noch einmal deutlich
gefährlicher sind als die atombomben
von hiroshima und nagasaki und schon
diese atombomben haben damals knapp eine
viertelmillion menschen getötet wie
müssen wir uns also das szenario
vorstellen wenn die welt jetzt in einen
atomkrieg schlittern würde die genauen
ausmaße kommen natürlich auch die
menge der eingesetzten waffen an
ich lege euch die fakten etwa auf den
tisch und das nicht weil ich euch angst
machen will
danke übrigens an dieser stelle an hart
walker von dem der vorschlag für dieses
thema kommt die erste reaktion bei
solchen themen ist menschlicher natur
augen und ohren zu und raus damit aus
meinen gedanken wenn die bilder im kopf
tatsächlich komme aus zu halten doch
findet ihr es nicht alarmierend dass die
meisten männer die über die macht von
atomwaffen verfügen im grunde auch
bereit sind diese im ernstfall
einzusetzen und dafür mich wenige
weltweit gibt es schätzungsweise etwa
10.000 atomsprengköpfe jede einzelne
davon anlage etwa 100.000 menschen auf
einen schlag zu töten
sie töten einfach alles und werden
deswegen von der
nichtregierungsorganisation icann
internationale kampagne zur abschaffung
von atomwaffen auch als verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit eingeschätzt um es
noch einmal klipp und klar auf den punkt
zu bringen
das heutige waffenarsenal reicht
tatsächlich aus um einen mehrfachen um
wackel auszulösen
also die mehrfache zerstörung unseres
planeten und nahezu sämtlichen leben so
jetzt bitte nicht 14.000 bei 100.000
rechnen das wäre nämlich eine
milchmädchenrechnung
und dass ich nun plötzlich irgendeiner
atommacht auf dieser welt weise
nordkorea russland die usa pakistan oder
indien dazu entscheidend atomwaffen
einzusetzen das ist nicht weit hergeholt
bereich nur ein falsch interpretiert es
eigentlich harmlose ereignis ein
unbedachtes wort zur falschen zeit oder
eben auch einen aufbrausenden charakters
bedauerlicherweise aber einen mächtigen
posten an der spitze eines landes
innerhalb gehen wir zunächst mal von
einer einzigen atombombe aus die über
einer stadt wie berlin gezündet wurde
eine trident rakete mit einer
sprengkraft von 455 kilotonnen
zum vergleich die hiroshima bombe hatte
eine von 15 kilotonnen
der feuerball hätte einen durchmesser
von etwa 18 kilometer jedes lebewesen
was ich in einem radius von acht
kilometern befindet würde verbrennungen
dritten grades erleiden also eigentlich
mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit tödlich
auf einer fläche von 16.000
quadratkilometer an gebe es radioaktiven
niederschlag etwa 230.000 menschen
würden sofort sterben etwas mehr als
50.000 würden verletzt sei dies hätte
zum einen die ausgelöste druckwelle der
bombe selbst zum anderen aber auch die
enorme radioaktive strahlung zu
verantworten
doch die sind wohl nicht die einzigen
möglichst tragischen konsequenzen eines
atomwaffeneinsatzes vor allem wenn es
mehrere atomexplosion wind ein
wissenschaftlerteam aus new jersey hat
mit hilfe von modernen klima
simulationsprogrammen herausgefunden
dass eine weltweite atomare eskalation
unser weltklima völlig aus dem
gleichgewicht bringen würde
das so die forscherinnen forscher sei
die wahre katastrophe an der atomaren
eskalation die explosion der atombombe
hätte zur folge dass riesige mengen an
staub aufgewirbelt werden
diese würden durch die unvorstellbare
hitze genau wie die asche die durch die
brände entsteht bis zur 80 kilometer
hoch in die mittlere und hohe
stratosphäre gelangen bedingt dadurch
dass die partikel doch mehrere jahre
bleiben würde so das forscherteam
würde kaum mehr sonderlich zur erde
gelangen
der sogenannte nukleare winter liege die
durchschnittstemperatur auf der erde um
bis zu 8 grad celsius sinken das wäre
tatsächlich eiszeit niveau die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus new jersey sind sich sicher dass
dies auch in regionen auf der erde die
weitab vom ort des atom skifliegen
große klimatische konsequenzen zur
folge hätten vor allem das erste jahr
so sagen die forscherinnen und forscher
würde besonders schlimm werden die
extreme kälte
diesen boden gefrieren und pflanzen
sterben die melodie
weltgesundheitsorganisation schätzt
dass mit den weltweiten getreidevorräte
etwa 80 tage lang die komplette
weltbevölkerung ernährt werden könnte
doch dann ist schluss eine weltweite
hungerkatastrophe würde seinen lauf
nimmt und nicht nur die extreme kälte
sondern auch die uv strahlung die nun
durch die zerstörte ozonschicht fast
ungefiltert auf die erde treffen wird
und zwar im nachgang wenn der staub sich
gelegt hat nach einigen jahren würde
die noch wenigen pflanzen eingehen
lassen
das resultat die ernte viele aus und
wohl die meisten die nicht sowieso schon
durch die druckwellen der atombomben das
feuer oder die strahlung ihr leben
verloren hätten wären spätestens dann
in diesem szenario verhungern nicht zu
vergessen auch das soziale chaos am
anfang des films dass wir relativ
schnell ausbrechen würde und das
überleben für jeden einzelnen von uns
zu einem wahrhaftigen kampf machen
würde katastrophen wie der hurrikan
katrina haben gezeigt dass menschen die
in ihrer existenz bedroht sind zu allem
bereit in die zivilisation würde sofort
zusammenbrechen denn dann lautet das
motto wohl jeder kämpft für sich das
forscherteam aus new jersey war
übrigens selbst überrascht von ihren
ergebnissen verwundert zeigen nämlich
vor allem darüber dass auch wenige
waffen mit einer eher geringe
sprengkraft große globale folgen haben
könnten
ihren berechnungen zufolge seien diese
in der lage pro kilotonne sprengkraft
mehr opfer und rauch zu verursachen als
diejenigen atombomben mit großer
sprengkraft es liegt allerdings auf
szenarien nach denen menschen in
bestimmten regionen der welt einen
atomkrieg überleben könnten nämlich
in den gebieten in denen die temperatur
etwas weniger wind den
simulationsrechnungen zufolge wäre dies
in der äquatorregion und an der
südspitze von südamerika und in
australien der fall
eventuell könnten einige pflanzen
insekten und fische die dunkelheit und
die starke uv-strahlung aushalten und
somit den menschen als nahrungsgrundlage
dient es ist also
ein ziemlich düsteres bild im wahrsten
sinne des wortes dass ich hier aufzeigen
musste sollte uns eine warnung sein und
wir sollten wirklich alles
menschenmögliche tun um dieses szenario
zu verhindern ein atomkrieg wird einzig
und allein zu einem furchtbaren ende
für wahrscheinlich alle menschen ich
möchte uns hoffentlich nicht mehr über
dieses thema berichten wenn ihr mehr
über andere interessante themen
erfahren wird dadurch mehr hier ein abo
auf und vergesst nicht den auf die
glocke hier geht es weiter mit
dunkle materie rente glücksspiel
schwarze löcher eine rolle
das war ziemlich spannend also am besten
drauf klicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt